thank you and YPG thank you and YPG
thank you nytt what's the significance
of the I can breathe on your shirt I
think if you looked at the exposure that
you got from the shirts like a LeBron
James wore it gets a great exposure and
is that a real a sensitive response to a
dying man's last words I don't think it
is I think it's a response to say let's
make sure we all come together as a
community and unify 108 officers across
the country that basically lost their
lives either in the line of duty or
other circumstances I mean the the FBI
released stats the 27 police drivers
were killed with criminal intent last
year I means that there might be more
that died in accidents but by felonious
acts only 27 it's actually the safest
time ever to be a cop in America I don't
think so I mean I said this before to
other reporters that you know we we need
law enforcement here because if we don't
have law enforcement there's gonna be
anarchy and chaos and there's people
gonna be robbing and stealing breaking
into cars that's not a world I want to
live
when you look at the police offices
themselves how did they defend
themselves they do it with force they do
a push well no when they love to use
force if someone's not complying with
the direct order from the police's the
deadly force which is what was used in
the case of Eric Garner's now do you
believe that was right you believe that
it was deadly for ever did the coroner
called it a homicide the person puts
their hands behind their back and says
you're under arrest and goes through the
process which he did multiple times what
would happen he wouldn't be hurt he
wouldn't died maybe he would have died
you know in the cell because he had a
bad heart somebody's gonna have a heart
attack sooner or later maybe it was his
time I don't know I'm not an expert you
got two black cops assassinated but you
don't say a word because now you got a
little publicity one out stop it because
I know I could see you come from the
suburbs right and you run around the
world DeBlasio he is not standing behind
them it's the prejudiced one he hasn't
supported he hasn't said anything
positive about the police who are out
there every day protecting everybody
never would have happened under Giuliani
that's for sure when somebody does
something you deal with those who've
done it you don't wash to size everybody
because of it do you understand the
anger behind the lack of an indictment
over the killing of Eric garner but I
think that we should go back to basics
and sit down at the table and discuss
like adults and discuss like human
beings and intelligent people go home
commies go home do you feel safe with
your husband out on the streets well I'm
out on the streets no
I'm going on trying to set a historic
low right now well you know what we as a
community need to change we need to give
up those people who are committing
crimes because we know you got to
imagine what's going through that cops
mind does this person have a weapon on
them
is he gonna shoot me is it gonna kill me
is it gonna run you know no matter what
when the cop tells you to stop you stop
if the cop tells you to sit down or put
your hands behind your head you do that
otherwise
[Music]